what's going on
reject nation Greg Alva here and John
here so we just watched The Mummy 2017
edition sorry Thomas the Cruz case a is
back in action running a lot of places
yeah and a lot of stuff I don't agree
with the Rotten Tomatoes at all I was
surprised by how great this film is yeah
I walked in expecting one thing and I
didn't get that thing but you know what
it turned me a lot along the way yeah
yeah I felt like the whole film was like
other clothes would I've delivered a lot
not as though is that really problematic
problem anything
I might not give it ain't I might give
us something you're like a 40 yeah yeah
I think it like 48 sub in I know like it
lost really 48 I'm like a I'm like so
we're doing like 38 to 40 get off and
friendly at the 40 if it lot to me were
lying to you I would go yell 38 42 range
yeah yeah
all right some positives about this film
Yonkers is the best part of the movie I
felt like even when I was bored at times
Tom Cruise can still keep me entertained
like I know yeah our staff like when he
was on screen I was being entertained
he's committed to this movie it's not
like watching John Eicher never go back
he seems like he's really invested in
this film I'll give that yeah the man
Thomas the cruise you know no matter
where he shows up even if I did at one
point kind of roll my eyes this movie
being like Tom Cruise really like and as
much as you do focus on tongue yeah he
does seem like he wants to be there like
he shows up he brings his a game and he
bothers to play character the is Tom
Cruise within a different shade than I'm
used to
that's actually a great point where you
said about like being iffy about Tom
Cruise being and this because that was
my biggest issue with he like men it
seems like this film is all about Tom
Cruise is the Tom Cruise vehicle and
while it is that is it I gotta get this
another way right now this
this movie The Mummy is a lot more of a
Frankenstein's monster because that's
how this movie is pieced together
they're like bits and parts that kind of
work but attached to other things that
maybe don't or are distracting at that
on their own
they're bad in content well know what
I'm saying though is that Tom Cruise is
even though this is his vehicle I wish I
didn't care about that anymore like when
I was watching the film I was enjoying
him the most and I was on board for who
this Nick character was like I was
reminding me of Nathan jury from
uncharted yeah like like a big in my
round I didn't get some job I need to
drink because he seems like a total
Nathan Drake type especially like the
first like 10 15 man to this movie I
mean what if the mummy was uncharted is
sort of is the update of at least
nineties version the late nineties
version I feel like what this movie kind
of does and what I'm willing to watch I
have discovered is go what if the mummy
was a Tom Cruise movie yeah that's what
this movie yeah feels like it is a lot
of the time but that kind of work still
and I am what I like from him to way I
Christopher McQuarrie work on the script
for this as well and conquers is not
really like a funny guy but he's pretty
funny in this movie there are some yeah
some solid lines delivery he did where I
cracked up yeah and it's we got
intentional joke there was one joke that
is definitely intentionally that got
both of us doing like a few rounds of
laughter like laughter shock that moment
was like one of the best comedic movies
in a long time because it was one of the
few scenes where I was like getting
caught up and I was like yeah yeah and
then when he said it the joke slipped by
me at the point where I caught it on the
end
yeah just busted me up and we'll go
Susanna spoiler is the midpoint of the
movies will lost me is lost the movie
John a little bit later in the film I'm
glad to keep readjusting the scripts to
that time I was like okay well I guess
I'll give this a chance because it
actually is that it's weird then you go
in like seventy percent
it makes for me I thought the first half
was very enjoyable because it's like a
solid half of the movie was enjoyable
that I was thinking to myself like this
doesn't deserve a 17% because it was
such an enjoyable first half I can tell
where Christopher Christopher McQuarrie
bit because this movie has equality that
the edge of tomorrow also had from me in
a totally different way and with
different results like edges tomorrow I
went in be like this looks like every
Tom Cruise Syfy yeah crashed into one
and then part of the great surprise was
like he starts out the movie being
completely not Tom Cruise like out of
his element and in this movie it's like
it started out being like he's like
actually appropriately freaked out by
everything he hasn't used to things
super quickly like and that's the shape
of Tom Cruise like I said before I'm not
used to seeing as much and that term to
me a ton totally yeah I worked and
seeing the darker elements of it you
know because I was thinking like that as
moving for me any horror elements in
this movie the first half yeah horror
elements in it that I thought really
worked and that whole plane sequence
that you see in the trailer was
fantastic I was like yeah that's a great
Saudi gorgeous ton even yank it you
can't deny to film that secret even the
Ariel in the crash was get really good
like that ambulance sequence and the
wood is pretty good and then after that
I was like well he's got a hop on a boat
you're both right like because the other
action stuff is pretty top-notch like
this and Tom Cruise does bring kids
performance commitment and also bring
killer production quality on the stunts
yeah totally totally and that helps this
movie out I mean go get me wrong there's
definitely flaws within the first half
as well but and I just think it's
enjoyable the first half you know yeah
the first half charms you in a way
you're not expecting by being neither of
the movies you expected under this yeah
it's not a universal monster movie like
you remember but at the same time it's
not just a typical action adventure film
yeah and it takes off running too so it
kind of walks at a brisk enough pace to
sort of start convince the anything but
you know there's things off within the
first half you know like they have this
huge ear Mummy prologue at the 90s
movies did too just didn't fit even
though it happened so early in the film
it doesn't mesh well
you mean the actual light with all the
gold lighting like yeah the actual
moment yeah it feels like it wants to be
out of a completely other I was thinking
like this movie would have been more
interesting if they cut out the whole
prologue because the thing with the
prologue with it with the mummy and
everything are you explaining who she is
they keep repeating the damn from
Finnegan all throughout the movie they
just keep repeating what went on what
she wants they just it's like they can't
I felt like a writing treated like maybe
the audience is gonna forget what this
is all about is so let's remind them
every like like every 15 20 minutes
we're gonna remind you guys about what's
going on this would have been way more
interesting if it just started off Tom
Cruise jeh Johnson they find this tomb
and then what's going on you're at the
audience going what's going on but is it
as a person who just saw this whole
prologue you're like let's hurry up and
get the money out of the damn company I
guess what I started feeling like well
the movie begins on a note that pretty
soon you realize is only there to make
you remember a plot element from yeah
like it's not cleverly blended in and
then you get that that ominous
intro it's been a while since I felt
like movie didn't give me much credit
for remembering things and really like
you pointed out universe building and I
wasn't thinking about it much during the
experience of the film to be fair but
now that we're talking about I'm like
they just take a minute to be like this
is what the stories about every 20
minutes and so I'm like I can tell you
guys want me to remember but for the
future and stuff except yeah kills the
momentum of the movie they're making
right now which is what yeah
Fortin because the thing is the movie
has horror elements to it it's it's like
spooky
it's creepy ish I think the Brendan
Fraser was actually more scary because
they go one step further with like the
body or damn this movie does like just
way better
it's just more of a complete movie
because this one has like some cool
gross things like some cool McCobb they
she had these ghoul minions and stuff
that are like minded meat sort of if you
like that effect not further still the
last half of the movie was that's what
really lost me I mean that's when you
start getting really into you
building and it kind of affect me at one
point because we watched this IGN video
with director Alex Kurtzman of the mummy
where he talks so much about like yeah
what makes a good movie word is if you
just focus on the movie and you don't
really work like down the road maybe
we'll focus on universe going I tend to
feel like the best way to build the
universe is to deliver individual
satisfying films and if the audiences
like those films the universe will begin
to build itself and when I watch the
movie I was like what [ __ ] there's
so much universe Billy in this movie one
movie on that little Derrick thing
there's like unnecessary stuff in it
you know I could I feel like this is
fine the same anon spoiler because then
the trailer they show you that he said
Russell Crowe is dr. Jekyll and they
show you in a trailer when he's all hide
it out yeah so the trailer was already
ruined that that he does have a hide
scene and a whole crate the whole hide
stuff is it's done in a way where like
hey if you don't know who dr. Jekyll and
mr. Hyde is they're giving a lot of time
to this and you're still if you don't
know who Jekyll and Hyde is you're like
I don't know what the hell's going on so
it's intentionally meant for people who
know who Jekyll and Hyde are and it's
unnecessary a lot of that but stuff I
don't know and it starts to slow down a
lot in the last half like the beginning
of the last matter they start explaining
with the that's the thing the whole
point of Jekyll being there is we got to
explain the world that will connect to
all future installments yeah and the
thing is like he talked a lot about like
things being essential to the story and
and most of these new things they added
don't feel that no no because like I
like Russell Crowe's performance as both
Jekyll and Hyde like I thought having to
cool I don't know if that's the spoiler
but like is technically but I thought he
was good and I even like the concept of
per diem but it seemed like they lost it
in just kind of bleeding in phones yeah
it was just like wow they had like with
the bits are losing any life that's not
the problem for for me there was start
losing a lot of soul and focus because I
think about about some of that extra
stuff that isn't Mummy related is the
movie
we'll take time out of the army story
and dedicated to that and then forget
how time moves in the actual yeah Dori
and then things stopped making sense and
then the stakes go down yeah it's like
if I know something you're trying to do
to stop this the time doesn't apply that
I'm not invested in it yeah I mentioned
and it does have like x-men apocalypse
[ __ ] in there yeah it's like you know
it's weird stuff that I just John dies
is that the question and when it
happened like it might seem like just a
diptych you know the trigger when they
show you like it looks like sand boom
Tom Cruise and then the chick of running
and then there's glass and like when
everything's exploding all that stuff is
made up of glass and it's just loading
from buildings on to people like how do
I know buddy heaven - boy right - not so
gory yeah
Robbins is not discussed there yet or at
least like Hickey pains yeah you know
like if you look at any movie where
somebody has to step on glass or like
touches in their hands just that alone
in here that long and that's a moment
where this movie cops down being a
horror movie to be an action movie yeah
the last half when they introduced when
they start introducing all the universe
building stuff it takes away its focus
from its main plot which was interesting
enough and had me on board the whole
first half yep had me on board I'm like
I'm gonna be able to sit through this is
not a problem I don't know everything
and and and this movie pleasantly kind
of proved that to me because they took a
direction that I wasn't expecting and it
was actually pretty fun you know when it
got to be its own thing for a while oh
no I get that I'm saying that like the
last half though yeah it totally derives
focus from every from from all that and
I'm at a time for trying to get back to
the focus of the main products like nah
my mind is like not interested anymore
yeah the last 10 minutes of this movie
is just not like people were laughing at
serious [ __ ] like serious dialogue this
was bad an impactful moment people sort
of laughing as if everyone's like this
is just ridiculous this is stupid
yeah because again like that it you got
it bad
to be a real movie and win us back in
because the thing is maybe it's just my
viewing experience but the movie partly
won me over so much pasted on the charm
and humor and if you try to sell me the
mug based on charming humour before I
wouldn't have been that interested but
that one man even sub-state they ate
from other movies like there's an
American Werewolf in London thing that
happens that heart way and I thought was
pretty I liked it I liked it at a
certain point it's it's old that
interesting thing a way to be it's dark
ending and like it didn't ever earn you
back so when you get used to not taken
much seriously and that's what makes
this movie work and then they get
serious and like character arctic stuff
yeah that is so expositional like
there's a line said in the first like 15
minutes of this film that took Nick
conquers character and I said to John I
was like oh this means what his arc is
gonna get it all out they mean by the
end of his movie he's gonna be like
there's evil in you yeah it's like red
that's another thing with the IGN part
is alex kurtzman one in there saying
like you know what makes these movies
were that strong character those
original monster films were they were
character films and they were played by
movie stars who imbued those monsters
with a heartbreak and an agony and the
pecos and an emotion that I think is so
specific to the Universal Monsters and
how I sort of like you want to have that
you have character in this movie because
the problem is - if you're talking about
strong characters nice and good actors
to play the monsters and to give them
life and to make you be afraid for them
just as much you're afraid of them and
the thing is I like sofia boutella
a lot in this movie even I like her
every time I've seen her like me I don't
like the third thing I thought she was
cool the problem is they didn't take
advantage of her hardly at all like they
took time away from her to do their
universe building [ __ ] and I'm like all
that I know about her she's kind of
angry and she wants this dagger I don't
fear for her and there's how many times
they repeated the plot point of it I
just kept going wait
you want to destroy the world I don't
know I just didn't go back and watch the
99 money yeah what she'll notice I think
I mean Linda movies got you know seams
on it but they take a good amount of
time to be like Imhotep this is what
this guy's about here's what happened to
him you understand why he might be
better this one just doesn't do that and
it doesn't it doesn't give her any
dimension you know it makes her a big
bad it's telling you it's because of the
midpoint that ruins the entirety of the
film's effects it's building her up
throughout in the first half like okay I
get it Tom Cruise good guy mommy bad and
then after why I was more to think about
it now and that's I guess that's why I
stayed on longer than maybe you did
because every time something new
happened because new things kept
happening so even new stuff I wasn't
that excited to see I was to like well
this seems like it's building something
and it might pay off yeah but it but so
little of it actually does happen the
payoff the finale the climax of the
movie the big moment that you got to do
the title is justice for it kind of
fizzled you know it doesn't leave an
impact much one way or the other there's
an annoying ending given and knowing
anything to me yeah that is a lot it's
annoying as a kid yeah I'm going to have
so much potential like I even partway
through was like I can see how this dark
universe could work and even leaving it
now as much I mean it pick even like you
could fix it I think you I think any
feature is long and you could fix it and
I think they would be smart not to pull
the plug if this doesn't do well because
yeah it's like they've already talked
about Oh Bill Condon and he's going to
do a different thing and they're smart
enough now to know we've learned with
all these other movies that Ferg better
or worse they pay attention to the
things they want their universe to work
in the thing about Universal Monsters is
they can still you know I never want a
movie to be a financial failure like if
it gets terrible reviews like I don't
have I'm like alright the movie sucks
and in a lot of ways probably but what I
never wish that a movie fails at the box
up so I'm like that's a lot of people
have worked on
a lot of money oh wait it'll even like I
don't like BBS but how I'm hoping that
it makes it this money back earn your
budget yeah like I would like you to
still make your money back I would be
that was just doing your set accurate
would say way about this movie I'm like
I'm hoping it at least makes its money
back so that way we can get a future
installment of another darn Universe
character they can do it right and learn
from listen to all the internet feedback
in the world and try to make it better
Phil yeah I never get happy about the
idea even a movie I don't like or think
is deplorable you know like I think you
know people worked hard I do think they
can fix this because some some
franchises I'm like yeah I don't think
you need to be here but this is like
they have an incredible opportunity with
this right and they have something
they've tried a couple times that hasn't
worked yet but I think they can crack it
so because the thing about this movie is
as much as it makes me worried for them
it also proves that they at least got
some interesting ideas going like per
Digium is not in salvageable like that
could work next time I could even see
them changing up some things about Tom
Cruise like waiting to do a mummy too
and making that a little bit better I
can't imagine any of these right now
they don't this doesn't give me faith
for a lot of it I don't feel like this
is spiritually in line you know because
even he talks Alex Kurtzman talked all
that game in the video in that in that
interview and he's very articulate about
it he sounded very passionate or at
least very thorough and it doesn't match
that I can't tell if he's either doesn't
that's just his version of what I can
it's not on point or if somebody got in
the way or what it calls everything into
question now and the thing is they see
if they released that video this week
right it seems like they already maybe
know what people want to hear yeah which
is awkward because the mummy doesn't
match so I don't know what the score is
right now but there's still a glimmer
from all right well hey I would give
this movie you know I know we give
stupid rating all the time but to make
it clear I would never let this keep
changing already
like we do I'm gonna do a 40 I would do
like a 38% yeah I would say like this
was a 38% I'll give it up 43 because of
Jake Johnson just because it's really
kind of annoyed a and he annoyed me a
little bit - I didn't think they gave
him very good I just admitted a what was
their lines were bad yeah bad lines yeah
I thought he to me and this might just
be because I like him you know generally
when he shows up but he elevated that to
me those those lines because there were
times where I was like no it's not your
delivery really they just repeated the
same line again yeah as if that was a
joke all right guys we could check out
our spoiler review for the mummy on a
separate video if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe today become a
part of the reject nation click that
notification bell that John I'm free on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house and go check out
our patreon a lot of exclusive fun
content on there and person my the hell
out [ __ ]